no I agree you've got a point I agree I
I think like um women definitely do make
poor choices in men but um the quality
of men have kind of gone down
I don't think the quality of men has got
I really think it's the women but I in I
think so in in just regards to like you
said the father wasn't there this wasn't
there but I think sometimes people have
to take accountability like you said I
totally agree about taking poor choices
but once something has happened to part
of being a man is finding Solutions you
understand and rectifying certain things
so you see like it like if you have a
child or something and it might not have
been the ideal situation but it's now
your responsibility to you know to be a
good father to your children do you
understand what I mean yeah so therefore
they're not going to grow up with as
much Daddy Issues not just leave them